so China is buying up land across the
country including AG land
but some states this is sober versus
hard to believe it's real are helping
the Chinese government replace American
manufacturing as well the governor of
Michigan Gretchen Whitman has gave more
than 700 million dollars in taxpayer
money to fund a massive Chinese battery
plant in Big Rapids Michigan residents
there are protesting this tutor Dixon
ran for governor of Michigan she's host
of the Tudor Dixon podcast and we are
honored to have her join us tonight to
Dixon thank you so much for coming on
this is one of the stories it's hard to
believe it's real how how could Gretchen
Whitmer have gotten away with this
well how did she get away with this but
how is it not a bigger story what we've
recently found out because we gave the
the state of Michigan lawmakers and
Gretchen Whitmer have decided to give
this company 715 million in taxpayer
dollars but in the company bylaws that
are on the company website it clearly
states that when they get to Michigan
they have to have a CCP organization on
site a Chinese Communist party
organization on site a propaganda arm of
the CCP right in the center of the
country in Michigan one square mile of
CCP in the center of Michigan and that
has to influence the Grassroots of the
corporation so think about that they
have to have the CCP there this is in
the bylaws clearly the lawmakers and
Gretchen Whitmer read these bylaws you
would have to say you would have to know
what the company's operations are going
to be this is nowhere near any of our
car manufacturers any of our automobile
manufacturers so what exactly are they
doing in this rural area in Michigan but
to top it off we now know that about 250
to 300 will be housed at the local
University there Chinese Nationals these
are not going to be American jobs
they're bringing Chinese Nationals in to
take these jobs and they will be housed
at the local University where the local
university has just so happened to be
telling people this is such a good idea
you have to have this Corporation here
so how much money are the Chinese going
to give the local University
and Gretchen Whitmer who strikes me as
extraordinarily corrupt I mean someone
got paid for this do we know who well we
we need to find that out but obviously
lots of people are involved in this you
have lawmakers on both sides of the
aisle but you have Gretchen Whitmer and
and we have said from the very beginning
this is suspect and now you have the
community rising up so Big Rapids
actually said you know what we don't
want this in our in our town we don't we
want this to move out Goshen said we're
going to move to the town next door
they're still pushing you still see
local people coming up and saying this
does not make sense for us we don't want
the the arm of the Chinese Communist
party right here in our small town but
think about this this is truly an
organization it clearly states it has to
be the Chinese Communist Party setting
up in the middle of the country you're
surrounded by Wisconsin has a an Air
Force Base you have a lot of opportunity
to spy on the United States if you're
right in the center of the country and
they're writing clearly stating that
they are spying on the United States
I mean
it's Michigan a state that used to build
things right the self-respect is gone
it's so sad to see tutor Dixon it's
great to see you tonight thank you for
that amazing story thank you thank you
for having me
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight